and my whole life my mom always told me  She always told me  to stay in shape and I hated her for her  for a long time because she was always  telling me like what to eat and always  like if I gained weight she might say I  would always knew my mom would say  something put on some makeup like  because naturally guys I'm just a tomboy  I don't like makeup I don't like I like  looking homeless that's my thing and my  whole life I hate it I hated that my mom  was always on my ass about that [ __ ] and  now I'm grateful because all my friends  are fatter than me like all my friends  whose moms were supportive no matter  what they're all fatter than me I'm not  even an amazing shape I'd like to be 20  pounds lighter still but  over time I'm glad my mom made me  obsessed